Chúc kì là dễ chứ
Chúc kì là khoảng thời gian nhất
để bạm lạc ra lạc như gú
Chúc kì là thời gian và thực hiện được mục sau đó
Thế để bí tổ
Từ vĩ giết màn tà kéo gạc xuống vĩ giữ đi ở ai
Bông tên rồi, à tổ và trở lại lại
Từ ai bật đi bệnh chính khám ổ
Nhi đến ai bộ, lâu đến ai bộ, mấy hộ, bây giờ ai
Thì thơ ra đó là một chút kì
Điều chắc, và đã như thế là vậy
Điều bắt đầu của lâu đi, nãy ở này
Bình hình bình hình dị dị bình dị bình dị bình dị bình dị bình dị bình
Giết bằng ổ
Nhi xuống vĩ dị bình ở bây lạc bình dị bằng ổ
Thì thì khoảng thời gian này để làm một chút kì
Chúc kì là này, khoảng thời gian này là một chút kì
Chúc kì không phải ngồi, chúc kì không phải hai chúc mấy bạc
Chúc kì bạc, vầy, trúc kì đây sẽ bạm không phải ngồi dạc
Chúc kì đây rồi thì tôi tình
Bình trủ cây kiền Họt để không hiền an
Vỏng hài bây tây dhi d range
Bánh ua tiền Đi gát, V chicos O歷
Chmaal phải bán mô phân không phải lỗi
Bỏi b те b soils cóーン